two out walk ramirez reaches
curveball ground ball to shore polanco
charging fielding on the run and throws
out santana and that's out number three
instead out number two locko's still at
first base after the lead off walk a
rare walk from please sac and here is
eddie rosario the pitch
swinging a little topper back to the
mound please sack runs to first
underhand flipped and the ending
and that'll take care of the twins now
richard said
in previous conversations that he has
six variations of his breaking ball that
he can manipulate he changes the arm
angle he changes the
break the height to spin everything on
it
rich hill strikes out the side
now the curve ball gets reyes luplow and
mercado so two outs and now the guy that
you thought was the pick to click and
marvin gonzalez i wasn't sure if you
heard that or not and the one want to
swing at a fly ball into right field and
deep back it goes deep and goes
cupertino kid with the call
gonzalez to the upper deck and right a
two-run homer and the twins take a
two-nothing lead in the second
only been three for his last 36 but how
do you get out of the struggle off the
struggle bus
you get a hang and change up from zach
please second you hit it in the upper
deck also dio the batter number nine
hitting catcher i didn't think one could
come that way with the right-hander but
it's austin deal anything one line to
left deep mercado going back that's over
his head and that's going to be
a home run
ostodil with a line drive homer to left
just cleared the padding in left field
and the twins go back to back and have a
three-nothing lead in the second first
homer for the turtle now four for nine
at the plate
369 feet all this with two outs and the
twins have a three-nothing lead early
tonight
left-hander rich hill back to work he's
held the indians in check just one hit
so far hills into the line here comes
the pitch swung on and there's a high
fly ball deep left field that one's way
back there hold on jose ramirez
he's done it again second home run in
two nights
and the tribe is on the scoreboard
it is now the twins three the indians
won finally got one out over the plate
that he could handle a fastball and with
hill
that's not overpowering one out runners
on the quarters here is oscar mercado
now his one-two pitch swung on and
that's lifted high in the air to right
under it is rooker and he makes the
catch tagging heading for home and
scoring standing up is santana good work
by oscar mercado to plate the run from
third with less than two down and the
sac fly
brings the indians to within one run
comes up and gets rooker
this ball starts you start your swing
and then it gets you in the back wrist
and it
absolutely shoots pain all the way up
and down your arm rooker is having to
exit this game one out one on for byron
buxton
buxton first pitch swinging blast off
out to center field buxton going deep
for the second straight game
it's a two-run smash and the third homer
zach pleisek has given up for the first
four innings
another bomb here
byron buxton says all right you just hit
my man rooker
took him out of the game
going donkey kong on your first pitch
and
didn't miss
quickly skimming gobbled up there by
donaldson what a play
two outs
josh donaldson nice nice play to his
left a nice sliding play and then the
perfect throw to sleep
takes the double double play away
luplow buxton having to chase after it
buxton leaping and out of his glove
santana had to wait and find out what
was happening buxton's slow to get up
santana scores
and luplow is into third
he actually overran that ball aaron he
got there too soon and
almost jumped to stop himself he didn't
even need it he almost camped and then
he hits the wall very hard ramirez
single looking like a triple all of a
sudden
cut on it miss chasing a fastball
outside it's a big out number two
gets away
here comes ramirez and he slides across
safe took a tumble that's now a one-run
game
well if you can't knock him in let's
hope the other team catcher misses it
for a run two ounce mana board for eddie
rosario
rosario first pitch swinging away
absolutely club goodbye that is smashed
rosario's 10th on the campaign
you want a little insurance he provides
it in the eighth seven four twins didn't
even have to bother he just gives a
little skip looks in the dugout says
let's go boys
now so no
lays into one
out to center the shields at the wall
and he cannot make the catch it's
another home run for the twins
they go back to back in the eighth and
their fifth round tripper tonight i'll
do it again
this time in play routine fly ball to
cave in right field and that's how it
ends as the twins
wall up five homers